cuatro votos a favor 19 en contra uno
ausente queda aprobado el decreto que
destituye a los magistrados por la
asamblea legislativa de el salvador dejó
claro que apoya al presidente en allí
bukele en su primera sesión plenaria el
parlamento ostentó su mayoría para
destituir a todos los jueces de la sala
de lo constitucional y al fiscal general
del país unos funcionarios que habían
protagonizado encontronazos con bukele
por sus investigaciones sobre el
gobierno y su gestión es evidente que
los miembros de dicho tribunal no están
a la altura de las necesidades de el
salvador que claramente necesita
funcionarios más conscientes más
apegados a la protección de la vida de
las personas
el presidente buque le justificó que es
una decisión que emana de la ciudadanía
cuyos votos le dieron la mayoría en el
congreso minutos después del anuncio el
alto tribunal declaró como
inconstitucional sus propias
destituciones argumentando que pone en
peligro el equilibrio de poderes en el
país y creando un duelo de legitimidades
entre los magistrados de un lado y el
gobierno y el legislativo del otro
la decisión causó revuelo dentro y fuera
de las fronteras salvadoreñas la
oposición y los gremios empresariales lo
tacharon de golpe de estado igual que el
director de human rightswatch quien
opina que el golpe al estado de derecho
es total
además altos funcionarios del gobierno
de eeuu se pronunciaron en contra de la
destitución de los jueces y le
recordaron a bukele que la buena
relación entre ambos países está
supeditada a que respete la separación
de poderes